I'm grant Haley and we're playing start
bench cut I'm gonna be giving a category
I'm have to pick one to start one to
bench and one to cut remember to tighten
start what Rudy who can go in a bench
dead or cut that Friday Night Lights
will bench that Rudy hi I'm a start
Madden and I'm have to Vince Call of
Duty and cut GTA GTA bringing back
memories from the childhood but Call of
Duty keeps it keeps it going I'm still
playing Call of Duty i'ma start
telepathy I'm a bench
super speed i'ma cut super strength I
just want to know what people are
thinking you know if you one step ahead
of somebody you never know that could
make go a long way in business world you
know play making like I hear Tom Brady's
thoughts come on now that's more money
in my pocket
starting spongebob
I don't watch Rick and Morty someone
have to cut that [ __ ] self up Superbowl
when they wouldn't play to music
if spongebob comes out singing he killed
that yeah he killed start wings
seven-layer dip we're gonna finish that
and we're gonna cut pizza I like pizza
but the dip the chips and dip I can get
full of that and wings you're not gonna
play with Williams Branch Carter 3 I'm
gonna start that get rich or die trying'
I'm gonna bench that and the blueprint
i'ma cut my friend it did hurt it hurt
but 50/50 came different on that is that
with 21 questions okay so yeah we good
I'm grant Haley and that was start Ben's
cut